it might seem strange to hear now but
not long ago
state aid rules were one of the main
arguments the conservative party gave
for being in the european union we wrote
these rules in the 1980s to prevent the
french and germans bailing out their
industries
roll onto today and the government says
ditching the rules is a key
argument why it's countenancing a no
deal brexit
why so it says it can support companies
like this
ouijo a startup which works with data
from cars was given government support a
form of state
aid which helped it get through the
pandemic we're helping cities reduce
their missions for example so we are
we're much broader than just being a a
medium-sized employer in the northwest
we're actually adding value back without
the government support we would have had
to go through some significant sort of
cost reductions in the business um so
that support meant that we could
we could continue to scale up that kind
of thing was allowed within eu state aid
rules but
it was these rules which prevented the
government bailing out british steel
when it collapsed in 2018
after all they're designed to prohibit
the propping up of failing companies
that says this former advisor theresa
may was actually a good thing
they're trying to get rid of something
that probably mostly improves policy
those kind of subsidies are bad for the
economy as a whole they're bad for like
interstate competition and on the whole
what you do as a result of
having those freedoms is you put
politicians in charge of decisions to
fund money at companies and
they'll bang it at the companies that
are politically attracted not
necessarily the ones that will
generate a prosperous future for
everyone
another tech company which uses ai to
help engineers carry out remote tests
says while state aid in a brexit deal is
important
it's not the only thing for us brexit
matters in two ways
um eu regulations with regard to gdpr
and data security
are obviously in case of a no deal
brexit a bit of an issue
for us to keep operating and the second
one is that i think
a large part in the team come from the
eu i'm assuming that like access to
people
and being part of the common market is
probably more important
than the government funding the dream at
least of some in downing street is to
set up a trillion dollar tech company
such as we see in silicon valley in the
uk
economists insist there's nothing in the
state abroad to prevent britain from
doing precisely that
anyway whether most britons see a no
deal as a price worth paying for a shot
at having the next
facebook or google remains to be seen
ed conway sky news